Hmm,
so back to discuss,
to discuss.
So I'm.
So the fundamental thing that I learned
from Paul Rosin is to see us as these
amazing omnivores.
This is part of our survival strategy
even more than other other apes.
We are just brilliant omnivores and we
have the Omnivore's dilemma,
which is we've got to be interested in
all kinds of new stuff.
We're not tied to one place.
We can roam onto a whole new continent.
So we were interested in stuff,
but stuff has all kinds of toxins and
microbes.
We have to be careful about that stuff.
And so these motives have to be
intention and this is actually an
interesting way to understand the left
right?
Difference.
You have to have both motives,
but if so imagined two siblings,
one of whom is set more towards trying
new stuff,
seeking out new stuff,
and the other is a little more fearful
and we're like,
Whoa,
no,
let's,
you know,
let's not try that.
That stay with what's tried and true.
I mean that's progressivism and
conservatives and that's the origins of
it.
And if you look at kids' behavior at the
age of two or three,
it does predict how it will vote much
later.
Not Hugely,
but there is a clear prediction there.
So,
um,
so disgust is part of a regulatory
system about our engagement with the
world and whether we are just sorta out
there and,
you know,
we,
we seek out variety and diversity.
I think diversity is just a great thing
or whether we want a little more order
structure,
predictability.
Conservatives are neater than a
progressive's if you take photos of
their rooms,
um,
you know,
you can actually use the cleanliness and
organization.
You can predict how they vote,
um,
discussed.
It turns out what's really cool about
disgust in modern politics is if you
look at all the different things that
we're fighting over,
especially in this country,
our culture wars over,
you know,
going back a few decades,
sex,
drugs,
the flag,
immigration,
all of these things.
Um,
I have a study with my colleagues was
led by Seneca Leyva,
um,
in which we asked all these cultural war
attitudes of people.
And we also had their scores.
And the discus scale,
but one of the foundations of morality
is sanctity and purity and it relates to
discuss.
What we found is that if you know,
if you know what people's left,
right,
how they place themselves in the left
rightscale,
you can pretty much predict where they
fall on most cultural war attitudes
except for those that load on or
implicate sanctity or purity.
So what I mean his flag burning.
Okay.
Do you think,
you know,
do you think that people should have the
right to burn the American flag or
country's flag as an expression,
as a political action?
What do you think people can give some
answer in a one to seven scale and
people on the right?
Think more like the say no.
People on the left,
yes.
People who score high on loyalty are
more likely to say no.
People who have low run it say yes,
and that's even taking account of where
they are on the left right dimension.
But here's the cool thing.
Um,
it's only if you add in the purity or
sanctity thing,
but you can really understand what
people are doing because people see the
flag not as just a piece of cloth.
They see it as having some innate
essence,
some something sacred about it which
must be protected.
And so,
um,
so this is true.
They think of it as a unifying center.
Exactly.
That's right.
So if there's something sacred,
and this is the,
this is the central piece of my work
around politics and morality is the
psychology of sanctity.